Jake:202404 呃开了对吧
Jake:都开了都开了
Jake:好嘞
其他人：环境都没好
其他人：啊啊啊我错了哥yes
Shure: 然后它会跟我报这个
其他人：不你你现在create一个新的环境
Shure: 可以对你可以
其他人：就是缺什么装什么
其他人：这个绝对最快
其他人：相信绝对最快
其他人：对就你缺什么装什么
其他人：今天你回来必给你跑起来
其他人：哈哈哈这这这坐着三个
其他人：这坐着三个天天累环境的人
其他人：必给你跑起来
Shure: 我相信你了啊
其他人：登我号这样我看直接
其他人：你就随便create一个
其他人：你看看你python的版本
其他人：就3.10元就可以
Shure: 我跟我就跟我那个本地那个一模一样
其他人：他这玩意只给你下那种正正版的软件
其他人：然后他是那种
其他人：但你没有激活码
其他人：对啊
其他人：而且我操他们有没有那个微软的
Jake:北欧给了几个微软365的链接
Jake:但是没有码
其他人：我有码我有账号
其他人：我可以一会用
其他人：你发我就行
其他人：你也可以发我一个
其他人：哈哈哈
其他人：这不有个
其他人：你那个码是哪来的
其他人：腾讯的哈哈哈
其他人：能用吗
Jake:那能看到腾讯的东西吗
其他人：看不到他就是一个激活账号
Jake:好
Jake:我们准备买东西
Jake:我们要买什么呢
Jake:我们还要补一些
Jake:还有谁要补
Jake:你有要补的东西吗
Jake:你要补酒吗
Shure: 补点补点
Jake:你还要补啥
Jake:你琢磨琢磨酒
Shure: 酒饮料饮品
Jake:饮品好
Jake:路亚要补点什么吗
Jake:补什么
Jake:要补上补货
Jake:我们要买东西的话你要补什么货吗
Jake:雨轩要补货吗
Katrina: 我思考一下
Jake:好嘞
Lucia: 如果有蓝色系的明信片的话
Jake:或者这玩意哪有附近有明信片的
Katrina: 不知道我明信片里面有没有蓝箱
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: 就地取材一下
Jake:这玩意要收起来了吗
Jake:可以收收
Katrina: 收旺仔牛奶不收
Jake:不收
Jake:可拉倒吧
Jake:好那我
Jake:来我们来记个小本本
好啊好啊
Jake:来个人抬黑板吧来来来
Jake:可以找活干了啊
其他人：那不是考虑到之前并没有并没有货了
哈哈
其他人：还是要发挥一些作用
Jake:要做足
其他人：抬出去能放过我吗
Jake:哎呀稳得很
Jake:稳的一批
Jake:放边上吧
Jake:放放那放这个最左边
Jake:那边
Jake:有个阴凉比较好看
这边转转转
其他人：正对阳光呵呵呵
Jake:我靠正对阳光也行吧
Jake:这光是怎么打的 QA
Katrina:  哈哈哈哦Q&A
Katrina: 我不太会画那个符号
Katrina: 就是地球世界地球上那个问答
其他人：哦那还要准备问题是吗
Jake:对要准备问题
Jake:GPT准备问题
Jake:对我们
其他人：GPT准备啥
Jake:我们中午准备了一些问题
Jake:比如说比如说啥来着
Katrina: 中午那些也是问题吗
Jake:哈哈不就是不问问题
Jake:问题一不孕不育会遗传吗
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: 会会不会啊
其他人：是不孕不育是基因突变导致的
Jake:什么健胃消食片
Jake:能吃饱吗
其他人：健胃消食片能吃饱吗
其他人：能绝对可以它含糖啊
Lucia: 大家都很有逻辑的在回答一些问题
Jake:对可多了
Shure: 现在要干嘛来着
Jake:我们现在盘算盘算要买啥然后去买
Jake:你去干嘛
Jake:搞币哦
Jake:你在这搞币吧
Jake:你不用
Jake:陨石为什么每次都能砸
Jake:  砸中陨石坑对对对
Jake:啊在里面
Alice:有没有用纸擦的
Jake:有有有的有的有的
Jake:拿你拿到笔了
Katrina: 拿了
Jake:好嘞
Jake:刚刚你就问了一个好问题
Jake:黑板擦在哪
Jake:然后对就是个好问题
Jake:这不是喜欢问题
Jake:这是给AI的好问题
其他人：货币一般等价
Katrina: 我们等会出去买呀
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha:  我们等会要出去我们等会要出去买啊
Jake:出去买哦
Jake:也可以不出去
Lucia: 呃
Jake:可以派一波人出去买
Jake:最近天太好了
Jake:竟然都不下雨
Jake:HTTP error 没网了
Jake:服务器没网了
其他人：不他本地没网
Shure: 不是这服务器
Shure: 哦这服务器的
Jake:服务器没网了
Jake:没钱了
Shure: 怎么可能
Shure: 我今天早上刚给他充100
其他人：是不是没有export来看
其他人：就你没开
其他人：哎这不
其他人：这可以吗
Jake:脑废物乐园
Lucia: 我刚才一直看这个
Jake:对是吧
其他人：一秒一秒跑90%
Jake:这么快应该有cash
Shure: 500k每秒不可能这绝逼是假的
Jake:cache肯定是cache
Jake:cache cache缓存
Jake:cache那个单词吗
Jake:cache对对
Lucia: 然后原来那个文件夹是这个意思
Jake:嗯是
Jake:就随便删的意思
Jake: 哦对随便删随便删
其他人：对没联网
Katrina: 上次那个葡萄汁对酒他失败掉了
其他人：神经病啊
其他人：应该是有网
Lucia: 哦那个我喝一口
Katrina: 我觉得一般吧
Katrina: 我感觉西柚的蛮好喝
Jake:好西柚可以
Katrina: 那橙汁我也觉得一般吧
Jake:就西柚
Jake:疯狂西柚
其他人：哎我操
Katrina: 那要不再买一瓶气泡酒
Lucia: 气泡酒还有一瓶
其他人：买那个旺仔牛奶
Lucia: 有一个那个金色的
其他人：那个旺仔牛奶配百利甜
Lucia: 你要甜死我
其他人：和那个什么好像
其他人：红石榴糖浆啊
Katrina: 咱还有什么酒来着
Katrina: 那一瓶是什么呀
Jake:39的那个酒吧
Jake:39那个开了
Katrina: 还有就是朗姆的
Shure: 你别去你在这帮我搞环境吧
其他人：我不如去
Jake:你可以去
Jake:这还是昨天的哎
Jake:   那天的香槟
其他人：我靠还买了香槟
Jake:嗯
其他人：不是你这个谷歌能搜到
Shure: 那个就行
Lucia: 那个就行吧
其他人：刚就这个
Katrina: 北冰洋还要买吗
Tasha: 买点可乐呗
其他人：刚我看上面不是BM吗
其他人：就上一个步骤上显示BM
Jake:可以可以
Jake:可以没问题没问题
Jake:维他
Lucia: 反正在我们
Lucia: 反正在我们目标关注地区这玩意也是合法的啊
Lucia: 我刚那句话要删掉
Jake:哈哈哈部分部分合法
Jake:部分合法
其他人：直接问GPT直接让GPT帮你写
Katrina: 蓝莓吃掉了
Tasha: 啊什么时候
Katrina: 什么时候买的买的
Tasha: 什么时候吃掉的
Katrina: 上次买的那个
Katrina: 洗了那一天
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake:今天带今天带
Jake:今天再吃
Jake:哎全遮住了
其他人：你已经熟练的使用度假工具
Jake:可以继续度假
Tasha: 他偷偷吃掉了我
Jake:怎么偷偷吃了
Jake:塞我嘴里了
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Tasha: 你吃没吃
Jake:吃了吃了
Jake:确实吃了
Jake:哎这边有电话
Jake:有个上海的电话
Jake:上海电话
Jake:搞笑
Katrina: 那明天就是那个串要买吗
Jake:串就美团吧
Jake:美团吧明天买
Jake:美团
Katrina: 那就烤点串
Katrina: 然后那个炭什么的都有了是吧
Jake:碳没有
Shure: 因为烧烤店了
其他人：从烧烤店买点熟的炭然后来
Jake:哈哈哈哈买点炭灰
Lucia: 这又是一个弱智吧问题
Jake:明天要是这天气就太阳能好
Katrina: 那个如果说要唱歌的话
Katrina: 你音响能接话筒吗
Katrina: 有话筒吗
Shure: 没有话筒
Jake:没有话筒怎么搞
其他人：买话筒
其他人：拼多多9块9话筒
Jake:哦真的
Tasha: 小唱吧
Shure: 大概一个话筒100多块钱
Shure: 搞一个要不
Jake:可以搞
Tasha: 租一个吧现在来得及吗
Jake:租一个也好
Alice:明天天气比今天再热一点哦
Tasha: 怎么要买空调吗
Jake:哈哈哈室外空调大风扇
其他人：买那个烤肉用的
其他人：烤肉用的超大
Shure: 你们回北邮吗
Tasha: 制冰风扇
Katrina: 哎是不是那个小青柠还在啊
Jake:北欧能带东西回来是吗
Jake:那北欧会有别的人带吗
其他人：你也可以接我哦
Lucia: 对啊应该买龙舌兰的
其他人：几点来明天活动几点
Jake:下下午2点半
其他人：那可以
Katrina: 那就把朗姆换成龙舌兰
Katrina: 都行
Lucia: 今天买酒还带朗姆吗
Katrina: 那就换呗
其他人：我说我俩明天来这吃饭
Jake:可以啊行啊
Jake:没问题
其他人：上午我上午接他然后
Jake:早早点来早点来
其他人：电子琴搬了
其他人：电子琴还有你的话筒
其他人：直接拿你话筒
Jake:可以
其他人：你想你想
其他人：是用你现在这个
Shure: 对嗯
Shure: 那他们来的时候就取了
其他人：你要把这个带过来
Jake:什么东西
其他人：台包包
Jake:台球
Jake:为什么你们要这种这种爱好
其他人：不是爱好
其他人：还很可爱
其他人：这不是很像推我吗
Jake:你们都很能打的
Jake:没有这手法
Shure: 哈哈哈被称为北邮丁俊晖知道吗
Shure: 听说你叫北邮奥沙利文
其他人：我是北邮塞尔比
Jake:我们一辆车能抓几个人
Jake:4个 5个人
Shure: 有个人能留在这帮我配环境
Jake:哈哈哈要不然就是你吧
Jake:哈哈哈哈
其他人：不是你先搞一个
其他人：你如果搞好
其他人：剩下就只等时间
其他人：你可以把装起来
其他人：或者是就走回来就装好他
Shure: 他现在自己在这装呢
Shure: 我可以再开一个命令行一起装
其他人：别我建议不要
Shure: 哈哈哈嗯
Jake:好介意
Shure: 它下载速度是500K
其他人：我估计差不多
Shure: 回来他能装好都不错了
Jake:行啊走吧走吧走吧
Jake:两辆车走吧
Shure: 全全员都去
Jake:全都去还是再打一辆呗
Jake:还是或者或者
Alice:我在家吧
Alice:我在家等着那个快递
其他人：紫藤不来了
Jake:紫藤不来了
Jake: 行那56788
Tasha: 12341234
其他人：对的一个能4个
其他人：一个能5个
Jake:打车去哪啊
Jake:我们别去
Jake:我们换一家超市
Shure: 对那你们有山姆会员吗
其他人：建议那有
其他人：通州区万达
Jake:去万达是吧
其他人：稍微远一点好像有
其他人：通州区万达
Jake:有多远
Lucia: 那个在通州北苑万达挺近的
其他人：反正我好像上次看到开车时长
Shure: 只要有超市的地方
Jake:超市儿
其他人：超市那就万达呗
其他人：卧槽 7公里
其他人：7公里开车20多分钟吧
Shure: 它怎么不动呢
Jake:万达超市是什么超市
其他人：永辉
Jake:永辉
Jake:可以可以
Jake:那就去永辉
Jake: 去永辉好
其他人：半个小时我看看还有什么大超市没
Jake:这么远
其他人：靖康靖康你买没买那个大横幅
其他人：没买
Jake:我没买没买
Jake:没设计出来
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake:这这个这个太
Jake:回回头P一下
Shure: 它 如果error的话你就按一下上键然后再回车
其他人：哈哈哈哈
Shure: 哎算了
Shure: 我手机控制
其他人：你还可以这么牛逼
其他人：卧槽这个我真hold不住
其他人：手机控电脑
Jake:就万达是吧
其他人：啊这附近有个物美
Jake:物美很小吧
Jake:物美很小
其他人：建议万达没
其他人：没有你看这外边看着还挺大的
其他人：至少3层
Jake:哦真的
Jake:你打个电话问问
Jake:要不假的吧
Jake:假的是假的吧
其他人：你看这还能上电梯
Jake:哦那就物美吧
Jake:看给哪个商家一个表现的机会
其他人：可以先去那看看
其他人：不行就再7公里
Jake:行行
其他人：他这写反正人家评价说面积大
Jake:哦好好好
Jake:那就这叫物美是吧
Shure: 还行他真没有什么延迟
Shure: 都是在北京
其他人：啊都在北京啊那还好
Jake:就上物美是吧
其他人：物美行啊
Shure: 到底是永辉还是物美
Jake:物美哎人呢
Jake:去物美
Jake:如果不行就永辉
Jake:刘帅呢
Jake:刘帅哪去了
其他人：刘帅上厕所了
Lucia: 哎我觉得可以
Lucia: 谢谢
Jake:哎你你电脑放外边真的不会被烫爆吗
Shure: 晒不到吧
Shure: 快晒到了是吗
Jake:迟早会晒到的
Jake:你太阳你能控制太阳吗
Jake:你手机
Tasha: 真的不会输给我
Lucia: 我们今天的快递差
Lucia: 没送过来吗
Tasha: 你能打过我吗
Jake:嗯送了一些
Jake: 可以看一看
Jake:好嘞
Shure: 啊它断了
Jake:牛啊
Shure: 完成patch的安装啊
其他人：这么快
其他人：你说500K我不信
Shure: 那我估计就是在上午的时候
Jake:就是缓存
Jake:装了多少遍了
Jake:不存点东西
其他人： 怎会如此
Jake:有但是不多了
Lucia: 的基酒是不是也是龙舌兰啊
Lucia: 我靠等一下
Lucia: 我这两天是不是不能喝酒
Jake:确实
Jake:可恶
Jake:那就多买果汁吧
Jake:多买点可乐
Lucia: 没事没事大家喝
Lucia: 我可以帮大家调啊
Lucia: 但我不是
Lucia: 我是有点担心我调上那个
Lucia: 因为
Lucia: 我不知道大家分别喜欢多重的酒味
Jake:没关系
Shure: 我当你的舌头
1呵呵呵呵
Lucia: 碰一点点应该没事吧
Shure: 最好还是别打了疫苗的话还是别
Jake:你这回车撬的挺快
Shure: 我在敲back
Jake:哈哈删的挺快是吧
Jake:哦插脑袋上了
Jake:哈物美土桥店
其他人：嗯对那个真的大吗
其他人：评论写的大
其他人：咱俩上次去的可能就是那个
Jake:我们去的可能是我们没去的了的那个
其他人： 哦
其他人： 你说的对
Jake:差一点我们就知道他到底大不大了
Jake:我们
Jake:嘿嘿嘿
Jake: 你抓5个给你 5个
其他人：谢滨竹得坐坐我车
Jake: 行
其他人：坐副驾就行
Katrina: 还有充电宝吗没找到
Jake:有的达达的有
Jake:就你散烟
Jake:我散充电宝
Jake:哈哈哈哈对
其他人：我递烟你递宝
Jake:啊要宝吗哈哈哈
Lucia: 这个自带线的充电宝真的很不错
Lucia: 少带一根线
Jake:嗯
Jake:哎这怎么这
Shure: 所有快递都要跟他说他才拿的
Shure: 还是说他直接报他的尾号直接全部拿
Alice:不知道
其他人：还有充电宝吗
Jake:你找找呗
其他人：刘帅要吗
Jake:你找着没
其他人：刘帅改变了主意
Jake:嗯
其他人：他决定先去看看
其他人：因为他觉得档次不如永辉
Jake:他先他先去看看是什么意思
Jake:先去看看档次够不够
Jake:所以我们先去哪
Shure: 刘帅他干嘛去了
Jake:他在外面坐着呢啊
Jake:打打电话问问呗
Jake:问问物美你档次够不够
够哈哈哈
Shure: 没办法京爷就是这个样子
Jake:你打电话问问
Jake:你打电话问问你
Jake:你这档次怎么样
Jake:你这跟永辉比比谁强
其他人：你家有旺仔牛奶
其他人：多少钱一个
其他人： 百利甜蓝莓草莓蓝莓草莓榴莲
Tasha: 你真要打电话问问
其他人：我问一下他们几层喂
其他人：你好那个问一下你那个超市几层啊
其他人：一个人问超市几层
其他人：两层是吗
其他人：大吧
其他人：那个
Jake:有有有这些东西吗
其他人：你家有旺仔牛奶
其他人：龙蛇尾他咬这东西
Jake:傻屌卧槽
其他人：草莓榴莲吧
其他人：我第一次见人问超市问
你们家超市有几层的
Jake:真问啊卧槽挺好挺好
Jake:哎呦卧槽
Jake:可以
其他人：喂你家串有几层
其他人：准备买哈哈哈
其他人：一层多少钱
其他人：是牛肉吗
Jake:什么什么东西
其他人：这次去吃烤肉
其他人：这个是牛肉吧
其他人：什么牛什么牛肉
其他人：什么牛肉
其他人：什么部位的肉
Tasha: 他问的吗
其他人：他长在什么地方
其他人：吃什么草
其他人：他叫什么名
其他人：长在猪身上
Tasha: 是你问的吗
Jake:是我问的导致的
其他人：问了说俩
其他人：应该还可以哦
其他人：就这个
其他人：这附近还有吗
其他人：我要去去永辉来回一个小时
其他人：然后再买完估计回来都快6点了
Jake:哦
其他人：现在已经3点半了
Jake:好嘞
Shure: （歌词）不想要别人走不了
Shure: （歌词）只有你知道
Shure: （歌词）因为你世界不再单调
Shure: （歌词）你的微笑
Jake:要不明天跳吧
Jake:你明天直接跳吧
Jake:给你搭舞台
Jake:我们去永辉问问有没有舞台
Lucia: 特别好用8小时速成的已经速成的特别好
Jake:啊就是
Jake:是学出来的吗
Shure: 不是
Lucia: 刚才的动作
Lucia: 不是那天那个
Shure: 不是哈哈
Alice:他随机的
Lucia: freestyle
Shure: 根据歌词solo的
Jake:牛啊
Jake:说完
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈那个走
Jake:  物美超市土桥店走
Jake:到底是哪
Tasha: 哦哦我没见过大的物美
Jake:那就见识一下
Tasha: 对就很小
其他人：感觉 非常有生活气息啊
其他人：简称很low
其他人：他这是两两层
Jake:没事搂一下
Jake:搂一搂给这个看看真实北京
Tasha: 嗯这是我的
其他人：哦你画的
其他人：这是你画的
其他人：你做的
Jake:画的
其他人：设计级
其他人：这不是直接买的就是这样的吗
Tasha: 我我一句话没有说呀
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: 是买的呀
其他人：对呀这不一买了就这样
其他人：然后就贴墙上
其他人：我以为你画的
Jake:哈哈总被他骗是吧
Tasha: 我什么时候骗你了
Jake:哈哈哈
其他人：比如说你从现在开始可以玩5部剧
其他人：然后马上又遇到你输了哈哈哈
Jake:呃就是跟藏彩蛋似的
Jake:因为一个币它就是贴纸
Jake:然后就客厅里面藏一藏
Jake:他们找找到就是自己的
Jake:然后就可以买东西
Jake:呃会吗
Jake:就看这个
Jake:中央银行怎么操作的
其他人：我今天一定搞出来
Jake:对
其他人：我今天不睡了也要把它搞出来
Jake:EGO央行
Tasha: 300个吧我给你凑九福星
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake:这画饼呢
Jake:哈哈
Tasha: 你不知道九福星是隐形彩蛋吗
Jake:完了
Tasha: 真的你自己去搜
其他人：好OK
其他人：我信了
Tasha: 七福星
Jake:信了真真搜了
Tasha: 九福星是隐形
Jake:真要搜了准备啊
Tasha: 就九福星的
Tasha: 他会有一棵树
Tasha: 这棵树会帮你战斗
Tasha: 三星 9三星5费卡也打不过
Tasha: 全三星5费卡也打不过
Tasha: 真的
Jake:遇到高段位了
Tasha: 自己搜
Tasha: 三星5费也打不过全三星也打不过
Jake:我这车还有9分8分钟到
Katrina: 棒棒
Jake:嗯
Jake:这狗是每个人放门口是吧
Jake:我们也得做点狗
Jake:你这样吗
其他人：哦这是要干嘛
Jake:就看门啊
Jake:看门
Lucia: 还要给他加花花吗
Alice:不是我那个腿还没剪呢
Lucia: 哦你后面腿还没
Tasha: 哈哈没事这样已经很好看了
Alice:面条狗
Jake:火车
Alice:火车
Jake:地铁狗
Lucia: 我是内有恶犬啊
Jake:你是恶犬
Jake:对可以贴一个
Lucia: 因为内有恶犬
Jake:你贴一个
Jake:那放射性物质哎
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: 给他写给他写
Alice:剪刀在哪
Jake:对
Jake:剪刀这边有
Alice:这个不太利
Jake:那
Jake:这菜刀强一点
Jake:这有俩菜刀
Lucia: 菜刀不能控制方向呀
Lucia: 你只能直着剪
Lucia: 给菜刀烫头
Jake:嗯
Jake:那
Jake:上面有吗
Lucia: 什刹海好像在很中间
Jake:很中间对
Jake:不能说远不能说远
Jake:什刹海算很中间吧
Jake:正轴线上好像差不多
Jake:正轴线啊
Jake:没有东西
Lucia: 就是这个这个这个大水
Lucia: 这个附近应该就是什刹海
Lucia: 我没记错的话嗯
Jake:要走个两环跨两环
Jake:很近的北京市哪楼近
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有没有
Jake:新加坡哪都近
Jake:相对于通州而言
Jake:我们这不叫北京
Jake: 北京市区哪都近
其他人：我在上海这个地方确实是路挺近
其他人：就可以走走路
Lucia:  我觉得我本科都不怎么出学校
Jake:哦
Lucia: 出学校太累了
Jake:对我新加坡也不怎么出学校
Lucia: 你在紫荆宿舍还在哪
其他人：紫荆紫荆
其他人：南区现在已经是高贵的强基计划
其他人： 新雅和强基
Lucia: 经管男生现在是在我
Lucia: 我们那会好像他们最早在31号楼
Lucia: 但是后来好像搬到了南区
其他人：现在应该还在紫荆呢
Lucia: 紫荆去上课真是把人累死
其他人：确实所以我从大二开始就不
其他人：上课哈哈哈哈哈
Jake:解决了问题
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake:对解决了上学难的问题
Jake:哈哈哈
其他人：睡到自然醒
其他人：然后然后就图书馆
Jake:走吧来几个人啊
Jake:来三个人
Jake: 来3个人跟我走
Jake:哎
Jake:物美见对好
其他人：几加几四 4加4
Jake:看门
其他人：5个算你吗
Lucia: 我给他俩拍个照
Jake:去啊他
Jake: 他去
Shure: 怎么了
其他人：那多一个人
Shure: 什么
其他人：没多啊
其他人：有一个人跟靖康走
其他人：咱要现在不6个人吗
其他人：哦哦行那走
Jake:这两个
Jake:石狮纸狮子纸狮纸狮子纸狮子
Lucia: 走四十四个石狮子
Shure: 石柿子是什么东西
Lucia: 石柿子
Jake:石柿子
其他人：来你打车在哪
Jake:呃打车在这
Jake:开车在那
Shure: 那我跟那边
Jake:好走
Jake:自动分流
Jake:自动分流开哎
Jake:把眼镜关了吧
Shure: 关了
Lucia: 到地再开
Jake: 对到地再开嗯
Lucia: 关按什么东西不记得了
Jake:哈哈哈complete
Jake: 走走走边走边关
Lucia: 检测到什么就是Memory什么什么
Jake:哦哦因为他要求比较高
Jake:对
Jake:就是他记的时间长
Jake:总会有一些帧会丢掉
其他人：还会丢帧啊
Jake:呃时间戳还在
Jake:你知道吗
Jake: Do you know?
Jake:你这超市大吗
Jake: Is this supermarket big?
Jake:几层啊
Jake: How many floors does it have?
Tasha: 他问了两层
Tasha: He said it's two floors.
Jack: 感觉有点不太行
Jack: It doesn't seem very good.
Jack: 可以去看看
Jack: But we can check it out.
Jake:进去看看
Jake: Let's go in and take a look.
Jake:我们前几天去的超市
Jake: The supermarket we went to a few days ago
Jake:太高级了
Jake: was so high-end.
Jake:全去的全是盒马
Jake: It was all Hema.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:然后我觉得全是盒马
Jake: I felt like it was all Hema.
Jake:唉
Jake: Sigh.
Jake:我觉得不能给这个
Jake: I don't think we can give this...
Jake:就是这太BIAS的这个
Jake: It's just too biased.
Jack: 小波尔全亚主义
Jack: Little Paul is a total idealist.
Jake:读书人
Jake: A scholar.
Tasha:读书魂
Tasha: Scholar's spirit.
Tasha:这个您拿着行吗
Tasha: Is it okay if you hold this?
Jake:行可以
Jake: Sure, it's fine.
Tasha:谢冰竹骗我说跟我在路路上打游戏的
Tasha: Xie Bingzhu lied to me, saying he was playing games with me online.
Jake:哦他没跟你打游戏
Jake: Oh, he didn't play with you?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Lucia:但是有榴莲耶
Lucia: But there's durian here.
Jake:这是什么个价呀
Jake: What's the price of this?
Tasha:嗯不爱吃干嚼的
Tasha: Hmm, I don't like dry chewing stuff.
Jake:啊这已经到超市了啊
Jake: Ah, so we've reached the supermarket already, huh?
Jack: 我建议先买一瓶补水
Jack: I suggest we buy a bottle of water first.
Tasha:这不要一个购物车吗
Tasha: Don't we need a shopping cart?
Jake:哪有购物车
Jake: Where's the shopping cart?
Tasha:不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Jack: 入口吧应该
Jack: Probably at the entrance.
Jake:我靠华为
Jake: Whoa, Huawei!
Jake:太神秘了
Jake: So mysterious.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Whoa.
Lucia:华为
Lucia: Huawei.
Jake:华为太神秘了
Jake: Huawei is so mysterious.
Tasha:哪呢
Tasha: Where?
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha:那呢购物车
Tasha: What about the shopping cart?
Lucia:我去购物车在外面
Lucia: I'll go, the shopping cart is outside.
Tasha:感觉这个超市有点不太正经
Tasha: This supermarket feels a bit sketchy.
Jake:这太村了
Jake: It's so rural.
Lucia:还行
Lucia: It's alright.
Lucia:至少这次咱能把购物车推出来了
Lucia: At least this time we can push the cart out.
Jake:对哎挺好
Jake: Yeah, that's good.
Lucia:乐观吧
Lucia: Stay optimistic.
Jake:乐观挺好
Jake: Optimism is good.
Jake:这车怎么样
Jake: How's this cart?
Jake:好车挑个好车呗
Jake: Let's pick a good cart.
Jake:还行
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:那就他了
Jake: Let's go with this one.
Jack: 至少他万向轮看起来是万向的
Jack: At least its wheels look like they're multidirectional.
Jake:他一直在转
Jake: It's always spinning.
Jake:确实很万谢谢
Jake: It's definitely multidirectional.
Jack: 他有一点
Jack: It's a bit...
Jack: 他有点歪
Jack: It's a bit off.
Lucia:他有点bias了
Lucia: It's a bit biased.
Jack: 他有个轮不转
Jack: One of the wheels isn't moving.
Jake:他有点锁轻
Jake: It's a bit locked.
Lucia:哈哈哈还是bias吧
Lucia: Haha, still biased.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Jack: 我心里有点过分
Jack: I'm feeling a bit too much.
Jack: 还可以有fire
Jack: It could catch fire.
Lucia:这不是一点bias吧
Lucia: This isn't just a bit biased.
Jack: 这个轮真的不会动
Jack: This wheel really doesn't move.
Lucia:缺乏鲁暴性
Lucia: Lacks robustness.
Jake:他这不平
Jake: It's uneven.
Jake:他是个三轮车现在
Jake: It's a tricycle now.
Jake:三轮
Jake: A tricycle.
Lucia:牛栏山二锅头
Lucia: Niulanshan Erguotou.
Jake:二锅头整点
Jake: Let's get some Erguotou.
Lucia:这才是真正的北京特产吧
Lucia: This is the real Beijing specialty, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 是吗
Katrina: Really?
Jack: 大红袍
Jack: Dahongpao.
Tasha:要不要把这个放车里
Tasha: Should we put this in the cart?
Jake:好买了一个pad
Jake: Sure, we bought a pad.
Tasha:买了一个包
Tasha: Bought a bag.
Jack: OK
Lucia:买了一个充电宝
Lucia: Bought a power bank
Jake:买了个人哈哈哈
Jake: Bought a person, haha
Jack: 我能不能先搞杯喝的
Jack: Can I get a drink first?
Jake:去
Jake: Go ahead
Tasha:现在就可以打开喝
Tasha: You can open it and drink now
Jake:对对可以
Jake: Yes, yes, you can
Tasha:对一般在超市里面吃吃喝喝
Tasha: Yeah, usually eat and drink in the supermarket
Tasha:然后拿着一大堆开过的去结账
Tasha: Then take a bunch of opened stuff to the checkout
Jake:可以那咱也喝点
Jake: Sure, let's have some too
Jake:我请你们喝
Jake: It's on me
Tasha:冰糖雪梨冰红茶
Tasha: Iced pear tea, iced black tea
Lucia:你要报菜名了吗
Lucia: Are you naming dishes now?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:喝不出来
Jake: Can't taste it
Jake:你来你来
Jake: You try, you try
Jake:你报报他
Jake: You name it
Lucia:哈哈冰糖雪梨冰红茶
Lucia: Hahaha, iced pear tea, iced black tea
Lucia:可口可乐
Lucia: Coca-Cola
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Jake:元气森林雪碧丝绒拿铁
Jake: Genki Forest, Sprite, velvet latte
Jack: 常温
Jack: Room temperature
Jake:走转一圈吧
Jake: Let's take a walk
Jack: 你推吗
Jack: Are you pushing?
Jake:额一滑推
Jake: Uh, one slide push
Lucia:那个我也好久没喝了
Lucia: I haven't had that in a long time
Jake:哪个橙汁
Jake: Which one, orange juice?
Lucia:有一个叫库尔
Lucia: There's one called Cool
Jake:哦库尔哦
Jake: Oh, Cool, right
Jack: 哦是那个
Jack: Oh, that one
Jack: 嗯那个什么
Jack: Yeah, that one
Jack: 类似那种
Jack: Something like that
Jake:20年前
Jake: 20 years ago
Lucia:对小时候好像
Lucia: Yeah, when we were kids
Jack: 动画表情那个小孩
Jack: The one with the cartoon kid
Jake:哎呀这哪去了这是
Jake: Oh man, where did it go?
Jack: 还有8S这个非常大的8S
Jack: And there's this big 8S, really huge 8S
Jack: 哦还真的是有二层
Jack: Oh, there's actually a second floor
Lucia:上面这二层看着像仓储式超市一样
Lucia: The second floor looks like a warehouse supermarket
Jake:吃什么东西
Jake: What to eat?
Lucia:仓储式就是Costco那种
Lucia: Warehouse style is like Costco.
Jake:这是大桂哦
Jake: This is a big cinnamon stick.
Jake:Costco OK哦
Jake: Costco, OK.
Jake:打打一下
Jake: Give it a call.
Jake:打哎他应该是打我电话了
Jake: Hey, he should be calling me.
Tasha:对就是
Tasha: Yes, exactly.
Tasha:我听到了
Tasha: I heard it.
Tasha:手手表一直在震
Tasha: My watch keeps vibrating.
Jake:我们一起打他电话
Jake: Let's call him together.
Tasha:呼叫失败
Tasha: Call failed.
Lucia:会忙线吧
Lucia: Maybe the line is busy.
Lucia:一起打
Lucia: Let's call together.
Jake:我们一起打他电话
Jake: Let's call him together.
Jake:看谁能打到
Jake: Let's see who can get through.
Jake:总会有一个能打
Jake: Someone will get through.
Lucia:这算群殴吗哈哈
Lucia: Is this like a group attack? Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:我们来四四个
Jake: Let's have four people.
Jake:谢宾主哈哈哈哈
Jake: Thanks to the host, hahaha.
Tasha:呼叫失败
Tasha: Call failed.
Lucia:我微信网络不稳定i don't know why
Lucia: My WeChat connection is unstable, I don't know why.
Jack:  unable to connect China game
Jack: Unable to connect to the Chinese game.
Lucia:我现在用的应该是移动
Lucia: I should be using mobile data now.
Lucia:不是电信的网啊
Lucia: Not the telecom network.
Lucia:怎么还这么差
Lucia: Why is it still so bad?
Tasha:对方忙
Tasha: The other party is busy.
Jake:哦对方忙
Jake: Oh, they're busy.
Tasha:怎么
Tasha: How come?
Jake:那就接你的
Jake: Then answer yours.
Lucia:你这个t恤标志换了
Lucia: You changed the logo on your T-shirt.
Jake:哎是
Jake: Yeah, I did.
Jake:对这是第一版
Jake: This is the first version.
Lucia:变成他们学校的校徽了
Lucia: It turned into their school emblem.
Jack: PSG了
Jack: PSG now.
Jake:这不是
Jake: No, it's not.
Jake:这是
Jake: It's...
Tasha:怎么办他不接
Tasha: What to do, he's not answering.
Tasha:你打电话吧
Tasha: You call him.
Jake:我欠费我停机
Jake: I'm out of credit, my phone is disconnected.
Tasha:欠费了
Tasha: Out of credit.
Jake:我停机了
Jake: I stopped the machine.
Lucia:他刚解释过
Lucia: He just explained it.
Jake:对刚解释过
Jake: Yeah, he just explained it.
Jake:打不出去电话
Jake: Can't make a call.
Jake:那就换一个人打吧打刘帅
Jake: Then let's have someone else call, call Choiszt.
Jake:他可能找不到
Jake: He might not find it.
Tasha:感觉这个超市好小呀
Tasha: This supermarket feels so small.
Jake:这个超市
Jake: This supermarket...
Jake:对一开就开过了
Jake: Yeah, it opened a long time ago.
Tasha:就是那种开了二三十年的感觉
Tasha: Feels like it's been open for twenty or thirty years.
Jake:嗯经典
Jake: Yeah, it's a classic.
Lucia:没事给AI增加一些数据多样性
Lucia: It's okay, it adds data diversity for AI.
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Jake:不能总盒马
Jake: Can't always go to Hema.
Jake:太赛博了
Jake: Too cyber.
Jake:夹不上
Jake: Can't pick it up.
Tasha:没加他算了
Tasha: Didn't add him, never mind.
Jake:路亚也来打一个哦
Jake: Lure, you call one too.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha:这么说我们都开始逛了
Tasha: So we're all starting to shop now.
Tasha:就这个终于打通了
Tasha: Finally got through.
Jake:哦这个你打通了
Jake: Oh, you got through.
Tasha:对
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:对哎你好
Jake: Yes, hello.
Jake:你好啊你在哪里啊
Jake: Hello, where are you?
Lucia:怎么跟第一次见面一样
Lucia: Sounds like a first meeting.
Jake:哪位啊
Jake: Who is this?
Tasha: 哪位哈哈哈
Tasha: Who is this? Haha.
Jake:啊刚好停好车是吧
Jake: Ah, just parked, right?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:地下停车场
Jake: Underground parking.
Jake:行行行我们在
Jake: Alright, alright, we are...
Jake:我们到华为等你们
Jake: We are at Huawei waiting for you.
Tasha:我们在
Tasha: We are...
Jake:我们在华为
Jake: We are at Huawei.
Jake:我们去华为等你们
Jake: We'll go to Huawei to wait for you.
Jake:你们你们找华为啊
Jake: You, you find Huawei.
Jake:华为对一楼
Jake: Huawei, first floor.
Jake:一楼华为好
Jake: First floor, Huawei, okay.
Jake:谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you.
Jake:哎人呢
Jake: Hey, where's everyone?
Lucia:那不是正儿八经的华为吧
Lucia: That's not the real Huawei, is it?
Lucia:那卖的可是衣服啊大哥
Lucia: They're selling clothes, buddy.
Jake:但是这不是华为吗
Jake: But isn't this Huawei?
Jake:我说那是华为
Jake: I mean, that's Huawei.
Jake:他是不是华为哈哈哈
Jake: Isn't he from Huawei? Hahaha.
Lucia:您说不是
Lucia: You say it's not.
Lucia:不是您说是
Lucia: You say it is.
Lucia:谁敢说不是哈哈
Lucia: Who dares to say otherwise? Haha.
Lucia:你倒着推他会
Lucia: If you push it backwards,
Lucia:他会更稳一点吗
Lucia: will it be more stable?
Jake:他他会更稳一点
Jake: Yes, it will be more stable.
Lucia:OK
Lucia: OK.
Jake:因为他前面导向的是稳定的
Jake: Because the front is directed for stability.
Tasha:我也想坐
Tasha: I want to sit too.
Jake:那你坐啊
Jake: Then sit down.
Jake:请
Jake: Please.
Lucia:坐这个吧浅一点好坐
Lucia: Sit on this one, it's shallower and easier to sit on.
Jake:请请请
Jake: Please, please, please.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh my.
Tasha:猜它是釉上彩还是釉下彩
Tasha: Guess if it's overglaze or underglaze.